[Music]
in stupid parenting news Oh No submitted
by queen of the Tiff's oh who that is a
woman crashed her car on purpose to show
her kids that god is great
that's a genius thing to do that's
really good parenting so she's like look
God's gonna save me and she's gonna
crash and be like I'm a live [ __ ] what
if she didn't I what about all her bills
gonna send her mysterious check in the
mail have you guys seen those
infomercials yeah Reverend Popoff
he's like one of the biggest scammers
ever who sent $3 and we'll send you holy
water now oh I hate that song he's the
guy that got caught for like scamming
all them he's like the megachurch guy
and he does all the healings and [ __ ]
and he can predict like he's cooking and
speaking in tongues and stuff yeah but
his wife basically had Bible study and
then she would write all these notes
about all the people that showed up
there and then she would be an earpiece
and telling him like all right this is
her name and then she has a dead [ __ ]
on or whatever and then you know and it
wasn't the Lord talking oh he'll be like
you have a dead aunt
okay she's telling me that uh she's
watching you yeah it's like a big
[ __ ] flopster yesterday Reebok shoes
that are white yeah had a ketchup stain
on your shirt how does that prove god is
real that when she crashes it I don't
understand what's not singing a puss it
proves that God's faked cuz wouldn't God
have saved you right or levitated the
car baby God's real bad teach you how to
perish I'm gonna crash my car it's like
I said God exists
yeah this mother this 25 year olds
mother from Georgia
her name is Bakari she has two children
huges I'm the Chinese restaurant Kali
Pahadi garden she has two children aged
five and seven her face really clear
eyes though great skin looks like she
was caught off guard like a [ __ ]
she's not even wearing makeup but she
looks good she looks like a deer in
headlights
hashtag Alicia Keys mm-hmm yes she
apparently was trying to prove a point
to her kids that God is real and that
they would save them so what she did is
she started driving she started driving
on the street and then she ended up
turning and crashing straight into a
concrete pole and there's CCTV footage
of that so I'll show you that right now
yeah we gotta see this with their kids
in the car with kids in the backseat
luckily no not hurt like how old were
their kids five and seven oh I hope they
were in like those car seats and [ __ ]
you know bow what is she saying in the
car Jesus I'm like laughing that like
got his kids in there I know dude
parents would you ever even think of
that doing something or just any kind of
discipline technique where it's like I
would have departments oh I didn't know
such a great idea but now I will do for
sure you're gonna crash the car to Paul
apparently she was screaming I love God
so in that case it would be Buddha
Israel Israel yeah she ended up closing
her eyes to as you were driving right
into here the kids are all testifying
that yeah they're all time a child
serves arrested on the spot and now
she's facing child cruelty charges and
her bail has been set to 22,000 what
does she do take a [ __ ] hit a crack
before she do that that's some crazy
[ __ ] she must have been really stressed
out oh really
was she on drugs she probably what you
mention that I mean like she was pissed
off at the kids if she was on some crazy
yeah she'd be like why did she have to
prove it so bad because I feel like did
the kids question it like mama gonorrhea
yeah what children stop oh my god not
the rail yeah cuz she was saying she was
telling her kids that if you have faith
God will protect you that's a [ __ ]
man she did the complete opposite you
know if God is real he's looking down
like this some dumb [ __ ] I'm gonna watch
his pan out you need to believe in me
well luckily maybe she's not a horrible
parent cuz she did tell our kids to
fasten their seatbelts before that oh
well I mean God is real right because
they did they did survive yeah it was
proven yeah because that would be like
[ __ ] up are really funny if like she
died yeah and the kids survived yeah the
kids believe that God's really do it out
the lake well the next thing we're gonna
do we're gonna set each other on fire or
jump off this you know jump off a
building all the [ __ ] sorry part here
that are gonna be separated from their
mom that is very sad with their
grandparents yeah what the [ __ ] dude
yeah well luckily they're okay nothing
happened to them and not to have a
stupid story to tell for the rest of
life you know how dumb my mom was yeah
it's on the news I hope they think that
she's dumb and they don't think that
she's a very genius because if they
think she's genius then they're in
trouble dude my dad beat that Jesus into
me me too yeah cuz like um so in fifth
grade I wanted to go ditch asleep I want
to go buy a little in school what else
he went into his old memories with the
belt so I wanted to go to public school
with everybody else after fifth grade
and I was like I want to go to the same
junior high as my friends right and then
they're like no you're [ __ ] up and
you need more Jesus in your life and I
was like I get Jesus every once a week
though that's enough Jesus he's like the
[ __ ] did you say that's not enough Jesus
you're [ __ ] up you need 7 days of
Jesus you could never have enough Jesus
and you started [ __ ] me up and all
Oh dad did that yeah yeah my mom was
backing him up like his [ __ ] hike man
too like my dad was like DMX do my
brother my brother fought back your
brother my brother fought my dad back
how old is he
dude it was the cool one of the coolest
things I've ever seen
oh yeah he taught yeah yeah it was in
the hallway and then I heard commotion
and I opened the door they're doing like
mile Tiny's back and forth we tie my tie
dog he stood up to him in high school it
was so trippy - cause it was like but
that's high school though his body's got
bigger even if I tried yeah I'm like in
fifth grade all right yeah but dude that
was such a trippy thing to witness like
well he's coming into his own man did
you jump into B janessa I just like
looked in the hallway and then I just
closed it do you think you would up
though like would you have if if you
both were in trouble do you think you'd
both gang up on him or were you do you
is so vile he was the scariest man alive
I mean he did knock my mom's tooth out
back in the day I find that out till
later damn bull uppercut to tell the
story about that piano well he did there
are several things like my mom had to
put a whole dresser in front of the door
he was like coming in like what's the
shining Oh Jack Nicholson through trying
to come through the door he was I'm
telling you it was the kind of ke rage
where it's like a demon enters that's
like they really black out yeah you know
what I mean yeah so don't ever do that
to your kids be nice
- but you came out good good to you have
you not listened to this whole day do
the 20 minute segment of me smelling my
ass
that's not good we're both messed up me
and my brother we're Sevilla's it was
mainly from your dad and that in my
house was haunted by a bunch of spirits
[Laughter]
so obviously the spirit almost possessed
me when I was like in middle school it
was worse dude they helped me down and I
heard whispers and all that story yeah
oh not here yeah I was like in Poway and
I was I had Bible verses that's why I
know I see through religion I had Bible
verses in my room there like that [ __ ]
don't work that didn't help me I had all
kinds of verses that didn't help me I
was like laying in bed and I hear
whispers like in like Bobby jump in the
swimming pool his room was closer that's
why you asked about swimming pools in
Vegas cuz that's how that's how he runs
away geez I only got the J in the e out
I was like Derrick strangling me I was
like let me live [ __ ] you Bobby
what is it make it sound like there's
[ __ ] bees after them and [ __ ] water
but some power dude our house was
severely haunted built on top of some
kind of burial water keeps them away
even they work for him it worked for my
brother and my and then I ain't question
of my parents about it later in life I
go just tell me I mean oh my dad's had
eight strokes I want to know you know
and he's like eight strokes yeah [ __ ]
not well not in that house but like
later in life but I told though I want
to know before I didn't know when he was
gonna go you know I want to know the
folks are from behavior said yeah we
were scared every time he parked his car
in the garage he would have to run from
the garage to his bedroom
because he felt like they're trying to
grab on to him your dad my dad [ __ ] so
every family member my mom my dad my
brother yeah therefore I grew up in
that's a [ __ ] scary ass lifestyle man
right that into a movie
I mean Paulie how Indian can you get
highway that's derivative of a native
Indian name it's like aqua if something
like that Poway is derivative of a
Native American name it sounds like
right right yeah [ __ ] Pechanga dude
that's Indian as hell yeah
Tonga I'm telling you it wasn't just one
spirit it was like a grave you're all of
them like you cuz it was only on that
side of the house too
oh that's why it was one bedroom yeah
all of our bedrooms were on this that's
funny your dad's like [ __ ] dad put the
kids on that side but check this out
that's why we built we extended the
other side of the house we built a whole
more to build that whole different
section with their like the mail you
know why they didn't just move Asians I
say them they weren't that scared they
weren't that's good you know take a
guess that it wasn't enough for them not
to us I'm scary at [ __ ] you can look it
up one five nine four
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]